Tamar: Well, you know, in the '50s the working
class, the industrial working class were the
heroes in America and they haven't been the
heroes in America for a long, long time and
so they're hurting in a lot of ways.
Robert: Tamar Jacoby, President of Opportunity
America.
Thanks for being here.
Tamar: My pleasure, Robert.
Robert: And we're here to talk about a report
that you were the driving force behind "Work,
Skills, and Community".
Tamar: And you were a part of, too, and we
had a lot of fun doing it.
Robert: We did.
Why did we do it and what is it about?
Tamar: It's about the working class.
And I'm sure everyone remembers the campaign
for...in 2016 the working class was all anyone
could talk about, and there were furious sound
bites on every side of the campaign, a lot
of journalism but I don't think anyone really
got to the bottom of who these people are
and what their issues are.
And when we as a group of scholars started
to look beneath all of this sound and fury
and sound bites we found that they're a group
still somewhere between the poorest of the
poor and the middle class but having troubles.
They used to look like the middle class in
all but the income range and now they're starting
to look like the poorest of the poor in many
ways.
And so there's some real issues out there
that have been festering for decades that
no one's really paid attention to that the
2016 campaign, for better or worse, at least
ripped the cover off and got us to look, but
we wanted to look deeper and see if we could
come up with some solutions and we wanted
to do it in a bipartisan way.
Robert: And we found that their anger was
justified in some regard.
The economy's not been terrific for them.
What do we think are some good answers?
Tamar: Well, there's...we came up with a range
of answers and our...the theme...so we have
three dozen answers in our book and the common
denominator is work.
We wanna make it...we wanna make...get more
people back into the workforce.
We wanna make work pay.
We wanna give people the education and skills
to get work and better work and better jobs
and we wanna strengthen families and communities
to support work.
So the solutions range from unions to childcare
to college financing but the themes, the big
ideas are all around work and making work...putting
the work back in working class.
Robert: So let's talk about skills.
Bachelor's degree, a good idea for everybody?
Tamar: No, and the nation has been trying
to sell college successfully,
selling college for all for two or three decades
and what that has meant is a lot of kids have
gone to college who weren't really gonna do
that well in college and it's not because
they're not as smart.
It's just because they may be different or
the jobs they want don't need a four year
college.
So people are now starting to realize across
the country that maybe that was the wrong
focus.
I mean, if you can get to college and get
through and succeed and have the right major,
four year college is a great investment.
But if you don't get through or you pick the
wrong major, a very important choice, or you
go into debt you're...it's...often you're
worse off at the end.
So we gave a lot of thought to what could
a true alternative to college be for this
group, those in this group who for that, whom
that makes sense.
And how are we gonna pay for it.
Because right now the bulk of federal higher
ed financing goes to traditional academic
college and very little of it, just 14% of
it goes to what I call career education or
occupational education.
And, you know, I don't know exactly what the
balance should be, occupational or academic
but it's certainly not 14-86.
And so we gave a lot of thought to how to...to
what...how we can do a policy should be during
a time of national experimentation which is
a tricky question because the feds can't...shouldn't
just be deciding to throw a billion dollars
at this.
They...we have to be encouraging experimentation
and creating standards but also...
And also how to get employers involved, that's
another big question, but then that final,
you know, harder to wrestle question is where
to find the money.
Robert: So this was one of those right and
left coming together.
So we had six scholars from the left and six
scholars and experts from the right.
What did the right agree to that they might
not normally think they would agree to and
what did the left agree to that you don't
think they would've normally agreed to?
Tamar: Yeah, so the left agreed to modest
work requirements for some government programs.
I mean, everyone in the group more or less
agreed that the social...that the agencies
that administer these programs don't do enough
to get people into the workforce, that mostly
they give out the benefits and they don't
do enough to get people into jobs and everybody
was okay with that, with giving the...a new
mandate to the agencies to try harder to get
people into jobs.
Robert: And the programs are like SNAP, food
stamps, Medicaid.
Tamar: SNAP, the food stamps, Medicaid, everybody,
yes, yes, thank you.
But where we differed and where a few people
on the left gave little ground was whether
we should actually require people who get
benefits to work or to do some kind of work
activity.
And, you know, 87% of the public I think the
number is thinks that that should be but there
are some people in the left who think that
if you're talking about Medicaid perhaps or
food stamps you shouldn't have those requirements.
So that was a little movement on the left.
On the right we were willing to get...find
a few little tax increases.
We focused on tax increases that were places
where people who benefited from the corporate
tax cut, you know, in the upper end of the
income scale maybe have benefited, I won't
say disproportionately, but a lot, and we
have some modest taxes there.
But a lot of things...and this is...a lot
of our proposals we found ways to pay for
by, you know, as we used to call it cutting
waste and fraud and misguided spending.
I mean, on the education front that we were
just talking about, education skills, we found
in double digit billions by eliminating 529
education savings account, for example, which
go overwhelmingly to the upper middle class.
You know, our thinking about the...the people
that we're thinking about is they're kind
of the hole in the donut.
They're a little too well off to benefit from
many programs that are for the poor but they
don't earn enough or pay taxes or pay tuition
so they don't benefit from any of the programs
for the middle class.
And that ranges, you know...I mean, it's true
to some degree the mortgage interest deduction
is less, but certainly education kinda benefits
and childcare benefits.
And so we wanna even some of that out and
so we've...in a lot of cases we found the
money that we were gonna spend on the working
class in other places.
Robert: Subsidies for the well off.
Tamar: For the well off.
Robert: So skills development, a little bit
of work requirements in federal programs that
provide assistance without focusing on employment.
What are some of the easy solutions that some
politicians talk about that we rejected?
Tamar: Good, a very good question because
there are a lot of solutions floating around
out there that sound great and they fit on
your bumper sticker and universal basic income,
free college, Medicaid for everybody.
We said no.
We don't like those.
Most of them would be harmful.
Our solutions are more practical.
Often they've been...I mean, you know, so
let's take an example.
Universal basic income.
We think that it should be universal basic
work, universal work.
We should help everybody get a job, not give
everybody a subsidy to stay home and this...and
productive, people like us will work and a
lot of other people won't work and won't have
the dignity of work.
And so we rejected these bumper sticker solutions
and our solutions, you know, they can sound
wonky.
I'll be the first to admit they don't have...most
of them don't fit on a bumper sticker and
they need to be argued through but, you know,
we think they're practical.
We think they now have at least bipartisan
buy in of some kind.
Many of them have been tested in states or
are being tested in states and many of them
have been floating around on Capitol Hill
and the one...with some bipartisan support
but the one reason we couldn't...we haven't
been able to enact them is because people
couldn't agree where to find the money.
And so for example on the expanding EITC for
childless workers Obama has talked about that
and Paul Ryan has talked about that.
What they couldn't agree on was where to find
the money.
We came up with a bipartisan solution for
where to find the money.
Robert: And one more on what we didn't choose.
We didn't choose protectionism or a global
trade war.
Tamar: No, or a wall at the border or...
Robert: Ending immigration.
Tamar: Or ending immigration and, you know,
we understand that there's a lot of people
in the working class who feel that...who feel
or have been told that immigration is the
source of their problem or have latched on
to immigration as the source of their problem.
We don't think it is.
Certainly not the major source and maybe not
even a significant source and so we felt we
could come up with our solutions that we think
really are real solutions without going near
that very contentious issue.
Robert: So just describe for me...to be clear
who are we talking about?
What is the category or...
Tamar: Yeah, exactly.
[inaudible 00:08:32] working class.
Who are they?
So they have at least a high school diploma
but not a four year college degree and they
live in a household...the technical description
is between the 20th and 50th income percentile.
What that means in practice for a household
that has 2 parents and a child I believe is
between $30K and $70K a year.
Robert: And the perception in the past was
that someone with a high school degree but
not a college who wanted to work and participate
in the economy could do well enough to support
a family and that's not true right now.
Tamar: The globalization and technology and
the way the country has shifted, everything
from...everything in policy, I dare say, where
we've just talked about a minute ago, middle
class and poor getting benefits, upper middle
class, not these people, but also where investment
goes.
Seventy five percent of the venture capital
investment goes to three states.
So the...a lot of people in a lot of places
have just been left behind and they've been
left behind materially, economically, what
have you, but they've also been left behind
politically.
Nobody seriously thought about them and tried
to have answers for them or took them seriously
or, you know, gave them the dignity.
I mean, I'm not this old but, you know, in
the '50s the working class, and the industrial
working class were the heroes in America and
they haven't been the heroes in America for
a long, long time and so they're hurting in
a lot of ways.
Robert: So "Work, Skills, Community," we've
talked about work, we've talked about skills.
We also ask something of this group as well,
don't we?
Tamar: We do and community is the hardest
one, right, because what...how much can government
reach the community and how much can, you
know, the...any level of government, what
can they do to create new community and how
much can government really do to repair marriages
and families?
And those things...
Marriage, I mean, some of our really troubling
factual findings, marriage has declined more
in our group than in any other group over
the past 20 years.
It was already a bit low for the poor but
it's declined there but it's...and it's declined...the
middle class are doing pretty well.
Working class, down, down, down.
And the same way with single parent families
and similarly with social, you know, interaction
with people in your community.
So this is...these are...they're not just
hurting in that they've had to go from a $25
an hour factory job to a $9 an hour Wendy's
job, they're hurting because their communities
are falling apart and the bowling league…
Robert: Things that held them together are
frayed.
Tamar: The things that held them together,
the churches and the unions and the...and
all of those things are frayed or gone.
And so it's...
And the opioid crisis has preyed on, you know,
and filled in the crumbling, you know, rubble.
So, you know, what can government do about
that?
We encourage people to follow the success
sequence to get a certain amount of education
and get a job and get married before you have
children.
You know, we can't make anybody do that and
the government can't...you know, we can't
punish people who don't but we...
Robert: We also call on employers to do more,
don't we?
Tamar: We call on employers to do more in
that realm.
We call on employers to do more in a lot of
realms, both that realm, childcare, also in
getting involved in career education.
You can't really teach...prepare somebody
for a job without knowing what job you're
preparing them for and talking to the employer
about it.
So we go...
Robert: Often the best training takes place
inside employers.
Tamar: Absolutely.
Or with employers cooperating with the training
provider of some kind.
But so...and we also...so we struggled with
how to strengthen the communities.
Employers, working class men and women themselves,
families, we're kind of excited about the
potential of opportunity zones, new provision
in the 2017 Tax Act that will presumably send
some more money out into these places but
will only, investment capital, but will only
work, we think, if these places get their
act together to solve some of the other problems
around the...
I mean, my example is, you know, that City
X is gonna become the 3D innovation hub in
America.
Well, that would be great if they could get
some investment to build that but it won't
work if they're not training people to be
3D innovation technicians.
Robert: So you led us, our group, the six
from the left and the six from the right,
on some traveling out into the country and
we went to West Michigan and that was a pretty
good role model.
What did you see?
Tamar: We saw amazing civic leadership in
West Michigan.
We went to Grand Rapids and what has happened
in Grand Rapids over the last 20 years is
that basically the business leaders with the
government, you know, in cahoots and social
services as well has come together to say,
"We're gonna make this city work and we're
not gonna wait for the federal government.
We're not gonna go begging Congress.
We're gonna put our money where we need to,
and mostly I think important, we're gonna
coordinate and plan together and come up with
a plan that we then all follow."
And, you know, we saw a city that was just
remarkable in how...what...how well things
seem to be working.
And we didn't...you know, we were there two
days so I'm sure there's some potholes...
Robert: Yeah, it was clear to us that that
is part of the solution as well.
Tamar: Absolutely.
And that's part of what we hope...our thinking
about opportunity zones will generate because
we're seeing some of that in some other places,
come together and make a plan, execute it
together and that, you know, and attract some
money while you're doing it.
Robert: It was remarkable.
Community, employers, educational institutions
working together to help people get the skills
they need to have higher wages.
That's the key, right?
Tamar: I think that's the key and I think
what might happen...this hard part that we're
trying to address which is families coming
back together and communities forming could
happen in that environment.
Robert: Thank you.
Tamar: My pleasure.
Robert: Hey, everyone.
That's the end of our discussion with Tamar
Jacoby.
Thanks for watching and as always let us know
what other topics you'd like AEI Scholars
to cover on Viewpoint.
And to learn more about the working class
in America check the links in the description
below.